personally I think because you're a man
you shouldn't have any words you're
saying because I'm a man I'm not
affected by abortion I shouldn't have an
opinion on it pretty much okay are you
affected in any way by the
Holocaust not personally I'm not do you
think the Holocaust is bad I do so you
have an opinion on something that
doesn't directly affect you
[Music]
right who is this guy what up guys
welcome to the just cly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series before I start don't forget like
the video on your way in that's the most
important metric YouTu uses to push
these out and also get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt in the
description so today I'm reacting to Fe
a man owns a feminist with her own logic
let's go H calm down calm down no don't
tell me to calm down you disrespecting
calm down calm down you no you
disrespecting me okay all right I'm
tired the way you're acting is not cool
in my classroom Cal down you not cool
this is why we need male teachers male
teachers everyone says Pearl is just
just you know
crazy I told you so many times I am not
a he your name is Joshua I don't care
your name is josua you are wow what a
guy a whole man and you walking up me at
the end of you still being disrespectful
no no
no what hey guy about to still respect
me my you are Joshua and that's what I
is that right yes you are I told you so
many times yes I oh security security
back away you need to back back you need
to respect my pronoun you still a man at
the end of the day see who is this
teacher can we get this teacher on the
show somebody please reach out to this
teacher chill out chill out a fully
grown man squaring up to a woman half
his size talking about disrespect what
an absolute fragile little coward yeah
that's facts no what a bit think how big
this guy is as well he's that big and
he's that emotionally weak it's only a
matter of time before he actually does
something dangerous to someone mentally
unstable danger to society kick him out
of the school so you said white people
are racist due to socialization in the
same way that men are socialized to be
sexist and heterosexual people are
socialized to be homophobic so I'm a
white straight male guy not about you so
basically
I'm like I'm like Enemy Number One so
I'm a yes Pierce did you not know I'm a
racist sexist homophobe are your logic
sexist yes I'm not sexist and I'm not
racist and I'm not I'm a sexist I'm an
open sexist homophobe who are you to say
that every straight white guy in the
world is a well you did you are calling
straight white guys like me a series of
offensive stereotypical labels which I
find I find very offensive okay this is
where there's a problem because you're
taking it personally there is a problem
I am taking it personally yes when you
say all white people are racist as a
white person I mean most women are
idiots would she be offended I mean yeah
this person's actually a man who
transitioned I think to a woman or
something and then did you clock that
King that that was a dude I did not
clock that these surgeries are getting
better be careful out there Fellas on
blaming men for all their problems it's
just like if you were a little drunk as
a dude I think that I think that that
could pass wow I did not I seriously
didn't even notice check this next clip
out rud to sexism is and sexism doesn't
come from women so of course it's caused
by men this is a social you think women
can be sexist I don't think that women
can enforce misogyny a load of nonsense
no because it's you know think any women
can be sex women don't upold the
patriarchy peers that is not the
patriarchy what's that blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Cry
Me a River I'm a fake woman then go back
to being a man what the you don't
know what the Pat I explain it the
patriarchy is basically a structure that
puts men at the top of power
so not winning that inforation most have
to the five most powerful people in this
country currently are
women how does that how does that sit
with your
patriarchy women have more power than
men we have all these stupid handouts
these stupid privileges I want to see
all women's empowerment gone gone I want
us to just be in a man's world we wanted
to be in a man's world we're here you
can get any job you want to get you can
apply to do anything you want to do you
can run for president you can do
anything so why don't we just stop stop
crying and complaining and just do work
do
[Music]
work 99 9% of brick layers are men
should we have quotas for women is Brick
Ling representative democracy that has
nothing to do with the question the
question is if there's evidence of
structural inequality and oppression
because women aren't precisely
represented at 50% in all professions at
all levels then why don't we have a
conversation about having women
represented in all professions at all
levels why do we talk about the sea
suite for example why do we talk about
politics and positions of power why
don't we talk about across the board but
that's because it's power because women
are lazy and don't want to do hard jobs
you're welcome Jordan it's so funny to
me watching someone debate a feminist
because they just hate it when the facts
disprove their narratives they hate it
imagine that though imagine like
everything you believe in the facts are
just against you like it must be pretty
stressful that's why they're always so
angry all the time you had a life
sentence Oh there's me look at that get
get yourself a women shouldn't vat shirt
you about to be sentenced to prison do
you want to judge or
period look at people think I Troll and
I really don't mean it I don't like
complicated terms I think when we make
everything too complicated I think most
things in life you can come to
conclusions by looking in front of your
eyes and really just living in reality
we know that women are more emotional
this shouldn't even be debated if I had
a judge on her period I would be scared
I'd prefer
not what kind of dumb question is that
that is a stupid question why because I
just I don't I feel like give me a
stupid answer go ahead no I just I don't
think that um like being on your period
would affect your job in that way does
being on your period affect you at all
does it affect me it affects me
physically emotionally I can emotionally
I can step back take a look and be like
it was never that deep and a stupid
answer was
given personally I think because you're
a man you shouldn't have any words
you're saying that because I'm a man I'm
not affected by abortion I shouldn't
have an opinion on it pretty much okay
are you affected in any way by the
Holocaust not personally I'm not jewi do
you think the Holocaust is bad I do so
you have an opinion on something that
doesn't directly affect you
[Music]
right who is this guy funny that was a
good that was a good question men can't
have opinions on abortion does a man
have to pay child support absolutely
can't have opinions on abortion does a
man have to pay child support absolutely
definitely men because they get paid
more and they also don't have to deal
with sexual harassment in the streets
and if they look how stupid she looks
with her boobs out complaining about
sexual harassment you're sexually
harassing every man you walk by by
putting your boobs out you could get a
neckline like this it would be put away
want to be shirtless they also don't
have to worry about somebody looking at
them like they're just throwing
themselves out there okay so since you
oh my life is so hard I have to put a
shirt on Wow believe that would you be
willing to switch gender roles with a
man no because I like being a woman well
then well then wouldn't that prove that
women have it easier in society
otherwise women would want to switch
gender roles no that is not true women
don't have it easier we get judged way
more than men we look better we we
possess more in life because we actually
bring forth life can't do that but um
but once again then why wouldn't women
overwhelmingly want to switch gender
roles if men be for money it would only
be for money for a but most women
wouldn't want to do the work that comes
with money wom to try to be a man but I
mean so she thinks the only reason she'd
become a man is to earn more money but I
don't think she realizes if she became a
man how much more work she'd probably
have to do that's the problem but she
could just do the work as a woman and
still earn as much money if she really
wanted to but the point is she doesn't
and when she doesn't achieve what she
wants to achieve it's not because she
didn't work hard in her mind it's
probably because oh yeah the patriarchy
load of I stated biological
facts and you have a problem with me
stating biological facts and the facts
that I stated is for a man to have sex
with a trans woman he would be Hing
people being hateful towards people I've
stated very basic facts and you sit on
the other side and you're like you can't
do that as the supposed Godly Christian
man you need to be tolerant towards
people it is our job as Christians to
align ourselves with the word of God it
is also our job to as Jesus said Make
Disciples of the Nations and to share
the word of God and you make all these
statements about Chase you can't be
judgmental towards people Jesus told us
we are to Jud we are we are in this life
to judge with righteous judgment it's
not a Christian's job to just walk
around the world and be tolerant it's a
Christian's job to combat evil and to
combat falsehoods what do you rate your
looks on the scale of 1 to 10 I'm going
all right I'm going to rate them first
girl has heavy makeup on my gut is
saying six but I feel like without
makeup probably five um the next girl
they're all both they're all like five
six category um I would say five six
five you agree with that King what would
you say oh okay King says four five4 all
right I'm gonna ask everybody like a
seven like a 6.3 why would you not write
you guys a 10 what is the ugliest one
say that like we should be rating
ourselves a 10 I'm some of you guys
didn't get bullied growing up and it
shows it shows look at the internet
comes for me all the time there's
nothing you can say that my brothers
haven't said to me I have one brother
that used to be brutal brutal but he let
me know you let me know can I just say
something before you go ahead yeah you
know why you do that why you why
everybody rates themselves as six or
eight or whatever because they are
afraid of being arrogant it's not
arrogant to be confident to like
yourself and to yeah it is it's arrogant
to be overly confident I could say I
could be LeBron James and oneon-one and
if it was true then it wouldn't be
arrogant it would just be true but when
you say things that aren't true you just
look diluted you like your appearance
but okay there's a differ he's
overweight between confidence and
thinking that you're on par with the
most beautiful women in the world
difference between men and women when
they have friends is men will tell their
friends straight they'll be like look
stop being a yeah you need to do
this and this and this to fix your life
women they're just going to lie they're
going to oh wow you're perfect you don't
need to change anything yeah keep doing
what you're doing it's like no that's
not realistic as a friend you got to
tell them if they're doing something
wrong and fix it not live in a delusion
surrounded by a bunch of Yes Men check
this out it sums it up perfectly be
delusional if you don't believe that you
are think that you
[Music]
are once you repeat so I've seen this
chick before times a thing in your head
is going to literally come into your
life there is no other way you can rest
now you made a great job today be proud
of yourself you're the you
could have done better
today someone forgot that he was his
family's last
hope he needs to get back on track
before it's too late yeah women's
motivation is always just be confident
just think you're awesome and amazing
and special We're Men it's actually like
real actionable things do you want to
remain a
loser lazy who can't even stand to
run a few
miles do you want to tell your son dad
didn't make it because he quit and was
too
lazy yeah all of these things are true I
was I was so pleasantly surprised I saw
myself in it I was like look there's
Pearl um look at women want all the
benefits of being a man without any of
the work and guys we've talked about
this time and time again freedom without
the responsibility that comes with it is
slavery yes and that's what women want
women want men to be enslaved to them
for a lifetime for child support alimony
and a bunch of government benefits and
free unimportant fake basically fake
jobs like human resources project
managers and marketing where we do
nothing and are overpaid using the men's
paycheck no no no no no no no I am anti
this I am all four women accomplishing
what they want to accomplish but when
you're asking for all of this Freedom
that men have to pay for I am not for it
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I will
talk to you guys next time